let's talk about binomics President
Biden's out there
um
trying to make the case the economy is
better than a lot of people think it is
um
there's there's a disconnect between how
the administration sees itself and how a
lot of people see the economy
that is true and our recent polling
proves that I mean it shows that the
vast majority of people do
like the way this President is handling
the economy and as you know our numbers
show too the number one thing people are
worried about like 90 are concerned
about inflation so while they're out
there making this case and it is a full
court press I mean like several cabinet
members of everybody's out there
um it has translated into real life for
most people who still
you know have you know all kinds of real
world expenses from groceries to gas to
rent that have not come down in the way
that they would hope yeah I mean even if
they Tout
say wins on
infrastructure for example having a
bridge built isn't helping you right now
right they were groceries like when you
go there you still notice that
everything is a lot more expensive than
a one is a couple years ago and they'll
say
um rightfully so that inflation is
moving in the right direction but when
it hit a 40-year high last summer I mean
that's nothing to brag about so of
course you want to see improvement from
that and who knows I mean we're talking
about this because we're talking about
it and the administration's talking
about it but we're a ways away and it
may be more how's the economy in 15
months that may have more of an effect
on the other like there's always been a
strong correlation between the economy
right before presidential election and
the results of that election I suspect
that that is probably less so as we
become more polarized I wonder if those
external factors matter nearly as much
yeah yeah because it because they tend
when we're suffering in our own
pocketbooks we tend to punish whichever
party is in power and running the white
house so I mean we've seen that to be
true against Democrats and Republicans
um but yeah the real world stuff does
matter but when we look at our polling
too and when you look at things like
asking primary voters why are you voting
for the person you're voting for is it
because of issues and they line up where
you are or is it because you think they
can beat the opponent or you hate the
other opponents so that's why you're
showing up I mean there are a lot of
things that will factor in with the
economy too
um last November
um those elections
um the Supreme Court reversing Roe
versus Wade got a lot of credit for um
for getting Democrats to come out and
vote and now Democrats are trying to
fundraise and rally support on the
Supreme Court decision against uh
student loan forgiveness uh there's
still there's still an abortion fight
going on but now I think they're trying
to Democrats trying to pile on and say
look what this court is doing to you get
out and vote young people and and we saw
the day of and I think this
Administration knew that was probably
the decision coming from the Supreme
Court so they had planned their
messaging they knew what they were going
to say and that's it essentially is this
quote mag Accord is stripping away all
of your rights and everything good in
your life and so you can't elect
presidents who will appoint any more
people like the last three that were
appointed by President Trump now he's
using it to take a Victory lap on the
other side going out and at his rally
saying look what I gave you look with
these three justices that I appointed
have given you in these wins for the
writer for conservatives on the other
side but Democrats are absolutely going
to message on that you saw the president
that day making comments saying we were
trying to do things to help Middle
America the Republicans did not want to
help Middle America so of course
um that's the best way to handle a legal
loss is trying to make a political game
I mean there's a cynical view of it like
you said is that maybe the White House
never thought this was going to work out
and it was just
always a messaging thing
um which I guess could theoretically
backfire in the end it's a broken
campaign promise he didn't help you with
your student loans but we'll point to
the Magus that that's you know they love
to use that and he Mega extremists and
you know the language the White House
uses and the president uses
um but you heard the questioning from
our Jackie Heinrich who said to him like
did you give millions of people this
false hope he says no it was real hope
it was the Republicans who snatched it
away so I would imagine that's going to
be a theme they stick with
um there's this
this federal judge in Louisiana says
Biden Administration officials can no
longer have to limit their contact with
social media companies can you explain
what this dispute even came from and
where it is yeah so a lot of it it
involves these two states but also there
were individual plaintiffs who said that
they were censored these were people who
were speaking out about covid
restrictions and masks and the science
the medicine the vaccines all of it and
so essentially what they found was
through Discovery look there were all
these communications between this
Administration
um and previous administration they're
you know with these tech companies
wanting to censor ideas and so that's
what these two AGS in these states had
said this was a censorship Enterprise
and what the judge has said essentially
and it's a temporary as you know
injunction so we'll see what the final
decision is but he's like for now these
these these agencies these
Administration officials cannot be
talking with social media to tell them
to take down posts or things that they
disagree with or a disfavored position
and so
um the folks who were involved with this
and it was a number of Physicians too
who were speaking out they're calling it
a big victory saying this proves that we
were being censored and that the
government can't go around and do things
through private actors that they
themselves couldn't do when it comes to
limiting First Amendment free speech I
mean there and their argument is look we
didn't compel anybody to do anything but
but you know the government's calling
you up like when the doj is calling up
and be like you might want to take a
look at that tweet I'm not sure how a
business owner right is going to respond
to that how they're going to feel yeah
uh former president Trump's second
quarter fundraising numbers are in twice
as much of a haul as his first quarter
numbers
um are these are these indictments
making him making his campaign money
listen he was pressured about it before
the first one came down out of New York
that state indictment there he predicted
that his numbers would go up if he was
indicted and with each one that comes it
seems to prove his point and and give
Credence to his narrative that the
establishments after me the Deep States
after me they're going to stop me um
legally if they can because they can't
stop me politically so man it seems to
be working for him I mean politically it
is rallying people to him in new ways
and it forces his own Rivals to do it
too everyone in the GOP field has to run
to him and talk about whether they would
pardon him or not they have to talk
about him they have to talk about that
this is a Witch Hunt that this was not a
fair investigation I mean so they're
forced to do it so it only benefits him
politically listen this is very serious
legal trouble on some of these fronts I
mean this is real jail time connected to
this stuff and we're still waiting could
there be another Federal indictment
could there be indictments out of
Georgia so these are real things that
are piling up but for now in the short
term the political payoff is definitely
there for him I mean from who's from who
we know has been interviewed by by
people with a special counsel's office
Jack Smith's office we know they're
looking at election interference
um and that could be yet and which is
which they're also looking at in Georgia
efforts to overturn the the Trump Biden
election and how many cases are possibly
going to be stacked up potentially
during an election year well and that's
the thing is think about if you've ever
been involved with any legal situation
or anything like it is all concerned
assuming it worries you you're thinking
about it you got a plan if you're giving
depositions if you're going to give
sworn testimony like that takes a ton of
prep time with attorneys you just have
to do it and if you have three or four
or five of these going at one time that
is a real imposition on your time your
psyche your strength your physical
mental strength all these things
um I think in the case of President
Trump he feeds on this and he actually
gets energy out in the fight he's a
fighter that's what his supporters love
about him but the reality of juggling
three or four or five trials at the same
time you're running for president that's
a big drain Rhonda Santos has been
certainly not gaining in in the polls
um he put out this video basically it's
hacking Donald Trump for his support of
the queer Community which I'm sure some
disabled supporters may agree with that
attack that line of attack but also it
seems like a very strange Target in this
day and age well and when I saw I
actually was confused because I thought
is this someone troll
Santa's campaign campaign I really
couldn't figure it out because I thought
this is such a mixed message because
it's sort of right taking this attack on
President Trump that he's been too kind
or too welcoming or too open to this
particular Community
um at a time when Republicans are trying
to say that they're building a big tent
and there's room for everybody
um I I literally did not know what to
make of the ad when I saw it yeah I mean
it really does seem like for the for the
support you might gain with such a
narrow line of attack
um you're going to lose more than that
yeah I'm not sure
anti-gay Republicans right I I it it
just seemed very odd you know you think
about every bit of messaging that you
put out as part of a campaign it's very
well thought through you've got all
kinds of consultants and I you know
often time
um you Workshop this stuff I don't know
how much attention this one got her if
they thought this is something really
different in Cutting Edge and we'll see
how it goes I don't know but the
reaction I'm not sure is what they were
going for
she don't have to confront you about
your cocaine at the White House oh no
hey
the logs will sell we'll show I was not
there that day okay just to clear that
logs can be scrubbed that's true that's
true I give you my word as a bream then
I was not at the white house that day um
you've been at the White House describe
where this where the coke was found how
accessible it is to people I mean it
wasn't in somebody's office no and it
was a more trafficked area where
visitors would leave cell phones or
personal items when they would be coming
in to go look around the White House so
you wonder okay was this a visitor who
happened to have this on them panicked
remember they had it you would think you
knew a bag of that size of cocaine if
you had it with you going into the White
House did they panic and just ditch it
there was it a staffer who also at some
point this is a convenient drop I've got
this in my bag I forgot about it I leave
it here
um there would be a lot of people but
you listen as you said visitor logs can
be scrubbed we trust that people are
going to be transparent with us but also
there's enormous security cameras
um all kinds of protective staff the
president wasn't there so you would have
different level of protective staff at
that point there's not a whole lot of
legal Jeopardy here it's a misdemeanor
um cocaine possession in Washington DC I
believe it that tells you all you need
to know about DC yeah for the wild west
that we have there um
besides the legal Jeopardy whoever
whoever's Coke this was I imagine is
quaking in their boots because if and
when that name comes out they are very
Infamous for right for a while yeah your
employment situation is definitely in
Jeopardy and from what we know right now
they're doing fingerprint and DNA
testing to try to get some information
off the bag
Shannon bream did not definitively
I can't I will swear a sworn affidavit I
will sign it today okay Shannon bream
Fox News Sunday host good to see you
thanks you too thank you